most national parks across the country
remain closed due to the partial
government shutdown that hasn't stopped
all tourists from visiting hundreds of
people reportedly scaled fences to play
in the dunes at New Mexico's White Sands
National Monument over the holidays
before the shutdown lawmakers proposed
bipartisan bill to make White Sands
America's next national park mark
Strassmann went to New Mexico to check
out the desert oasis this is the most
pristine beach in the world
it's constantly moving growing evolving
changing this place it encourages you
and reward you to look deeper the
landscape is otherworldly 275 square
miles of sugar-white sand perfect the
Park Rangers we rode with it to New
Mexico's White Sands National Monument
assured us this is no Mirage but a
geological wonder the largest gypsum
sand field in the world sunglasses are a
must on this beach without an ocean
although there's plenty of surfing here
too the environment is ever-changing in
the backdrop of these white dunes ranger
kelly carroll says don't be fooled white
sands is more than a giant sandbox this
is a thriving ecosystem there's over 50
endemic species that live in the dunes
that have rapidly adapted themselves to
live in the dune this is an island this
is an island of life that's because
beneath the gypsum Basin lies a high
water table a giant underground lake we
found water
about a foot below the surface this is
old water this is from 6,000 years old
6,000 so in the heart of the desert
there's an amazing Oasis Herbert Hoover
proclaimed white sands a National
Monument in 1933 but there's an ongoing
drive here to upgrade its status and
make white sands America's next National
Park
we're about mow for whites and
superintendent Murray Sutter describes
the difference a National Monument
usually is recognized for a singular
resource or a singular event a National
Park will frequently have multiple
layers a little more complexity the
National Park designation also carries
more prestige which would bring more
tourists jobs and revenue
and nearby Alamogordo population 31,000
we're excited about we met GV Oliver the
president of the local Chamber of
Commerce
studies show turning white sands into a
national park could mean an extra 100
thousand visitors a year an economic
windfall of up to seven and a half
million dollars for the region National
Park just has that much more recognition
people are in the habit of looking for
those and going to and visiting one
potential issue the monument lies within
the White Sands Missile Range America's
biggest military installations where the
first atomic bomb was detonated some 60
miles north of the monument the
Department of Defense and the Park
Service had competing interests but
agreed to create a national park with a
series of proposed land swaps the real
pitfall is something else
America has 60 national parks almost
half were once national monuments
just like White Sands creating a
national park requires congressional
approval the challenge is that these
days Congress can agree on very little
New Mexico Senator Martin Heinrich
introduced the bill to designate White
Sands as a national park they know when
they go to a national park that they
should expect something special and I
think White Sands meets the bill as well
as anything I've ever seen but senator
Heinrich also knows politics in
Washington can feel like a clash of the
transformers this scene was filmed at
White Sands so what are the odds then of
this happening I think the odds of this
happening are very high I think the
question is when and it may take six
months or it may take a few years but
there will be a White Sands National
Park White Sands may have a lesson for
polarized lawmakers about the dynamic of
change one wind storm one rain storm and
every track here is erased for another
day for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann at the White Sands
National Monument in New Mexico I hope
it becomes a National Park and it's just
stunning you're reminded of the
beautiful landscape in America right a
little bit of everything incredible
places and if that's not worthy I don't
know what is all right today on the CBS
this morning podcast